that's the thing that's actually  lingered much longer than the behavior  of the other person is the shame that I  feel around like why didn't how did I  become that person like what did he do  to you Anna I mean we're just talking  about like a really kind of classic  um emotional psychological breakdown it  was uh I know that gaslighting has  become this kind of term  um that uh is  um very very popular but it was a really  sustained period And I really didn't  know what to believe anymore I I really  started to wonder if I had a mental  health issue and  um and I yeah I kind of dismantled my  life and for a year I started just going  to therapy and going to Al-Anon and I  was I have this like graveyard of  self-help books in my house that I look  at now and just go like oh man I was  like looking for answers in the wrong  places I was just trying so hard to stop  being crazy